during elaine maxwell's trial a teenage
accuser was asked why she didn't speak
out or fight back because she said she
knew she was isolated here in a mansion
owned by jeffrey epstein on an 8 000
acre ranch in the middle of the desert
isolated she said with just those two
people
the photos of that palatial home in new
mexico now come marked with evidence
labels the property revealed in the
trial as being central to the sex
trafficking operation of epstein
and maxwell's role laid bare by those
brought here their experience of what
went on beyond the gate of zorro ranch
and this is just one property in a
global portfolio in which jeffrey
epstein and elaine maxwell could operate
exclusive homes in new york and florida
and the virgin islands where as you can
see they could stay well away from the
public gaze and as the trial heard the
means to travel between them that also
kept them in their own private world
because behind the gates and the
security cameras zorro ranch has its own
airstrip freedom of movement for epstein
and maxwell and their guests here the
flight logs of epstein's private jets
revealed in the trial the world of the
rich famous and powerful in which they
moved
with maxwell at its heart a who's who of
politicians power brokers and performers
none of those named in court were
accused of any wrongdoing but they
demonstrated a couple with unrivaled
connections
the lawyer for some of epstein's
accusers ones whose allegations weren't
heard during the trial say it was
maxwell's presence that won the trust of
those who became victims
mr epstein would have never been able to
abuse the number of women that he did
had it not been for the part that galen
maxwell played
in that sexual pyramid
the wealth
and influence that jeffrey epstein and
glenn maxwell had throughout the world
allowed them to continue on this path
for as long as they did
the problems associated with their
wealth and and influence
is that they were always given the
benefit of the doubt in situations where
questions should have clearly been
raised
well the many hundreds of people
who have sent
messages of support those who know galen
maxwell point to her past and the death
of her father the disgraced tycoon
robert maxwell on his yacht 30 years ago
she was very upset
she was crying about her daddy she was
obviously you know a daddy's girl
the youngest
ken lennox identified robert maxwell's
body after his death the death of
epstein he believes drove prosecutors to
go after gallane maxwell they lost
jeffrey and um
she was the next
there's no one else visible
to punish for what happened to these
girls i think she was under the
influence
of a man who in many ways
resembled her father
towards the end of delane maxwell's
trial the jury was shown this video from
inside the home in palm beach in florida
where prosecutors say she and jeffrey
epstein committed horrifying crimes
their exclusive world is now no more
that house has been demolished for many
the memories can never be erased greg
milam sky news